hello i'm john c reilly it's me Sarah
Silverman hi i'm taraji Hanson and I'm
about to take the Disney Princesses quiz
to determine which princess I am let's
find out
pick a Disney meal to dine on the cake
from Sleeping Beauty Tiana's Phineas
said how you said
Remy's ratatouille from ratatouille the
porridge from Milan spinach puffs from
the Emperor's New Groove the spaghetti
from Lady and the [ __ ]
I love beignets and I love New Orleans
so I'm going with beignets Oh
I'm gone beignets all the way I don't
trust that cake from Sleeping Beauty she
didn't wake up I'm going to go with the
beignets she was a classic arcade game
to play asteroids Missile Command
pac-man Donkey Kong Frogger
or defender I'd have to go Frogger
pac-man
I wish miss pac-man was on you but it's
not I like gobbling DOS I did play all
of those games as a kid I want to say
defender which app do you use the most
Instagram Facebook Linked in snapchat
Twitter or I don't know what an app is
well I do know what an app is of course
but I don't use any of these things I
would have to say Instagram have to say
Twitter is my jam I guess I'll pick I
don't know what an app is because I have
to pick something choose an iconic
Disney villain song to belt during
karaoke poor unfortunate souls for the
Little Mermaid be prepared from The Lion
King
Gaston Beauty and the Beast shiny Moana
mother knows best from tangled or
hellfire from The Hunchback of Notre
Dame I would have to go pull unfortunate
souls from Little Mermaid
I'm gonna go beauty in the Beast because
that was one of my favorite animated
movies I'll go with shiny from Moana
what would be your favorite thing about
being royal the power the riches the
suitors the travel the castle the
parties the power hunting because the
power would get you all the other things
on the list being a red-blooded American
man I don't think much of being royal at
all to tell you the truth that's why we
have democracy the suitors no how do I
know they love me for me the travel I
mean maybe that I'm really a home kind
of gal but I'll go with the parties fine
as the music isn't too loud and we can
laugh and do bits castles seems so cold
to me they're made out of rocks if they
had central heat maybe I'm gonna choose
the castle because who doesn't want a
castle they're awesome
finally choose a place from
wreckit-ralph to visit King Candy's
castle the candy cane forest diet cola
Mountain Cart bakery junkyard fun gym
carts bakery beignets come on I'll go
junkyard I'm tempted to say fun gender
such a fun word I'm gonna say the candy
cane forest because that's where I met
vanellope
[Music]
I've got Cinderella Rapunzel and tiana
yes honey cuz I'm every woman I'm every
princess I am a combination of Mulan
Snow White and Belle you got Moana Ariel
and Jasmine you're hardworking and
independent while you're willing to do
the work it takes to get the job done
that doesn't mean you won't have a good
time while doing it
that is me is that not me everyone's
over there nodding you can't see them
but that is me oh my god this really
works you are an adventurer at heart and
are unafraid to run full speed at the
metaphorical horizon guess that's me
you're intelligent strong will basically
you're always calm cool and collected
well I must agree BuzzFeed
[Music]